This is a beautiful video.
This is a perfect video that I'm going to
play for you.
This is what you call a political trapeze
artist flying around wildly, trying to keep
it all together.
I've told you before that Republicans have
been causing a problem for themselves in Georgia
because on the one hand, they're insisting
and Trump has been insisting that the November
presidential election was rigged against him.
He won, but it was rigged.
And so Joe Biden claims to have won the votes
can't be trusted.
The Georgia Republican governor can't be trusted.
The Georgia Republican secretary of state
is in on it.
They're bad people.
It's all rigged.
And at the same time, Trump and the two Republican
Senate candidates in Georgia, Kelly Leffler
and David Perdue, these are the races that
will determine who controls the Senate after
their January 5th runoffs.
They've been saying, yeah, it was rigged against
Trump and make sure to vote for us on January
5th.
What?
Because the obvious question is we there's
a contradiction there.
The election was rigged against Trump and
presumably also rigged against them in November.
Maybe Loffler and Perdue would have won had
it not been rigged.
But because of the rigging, now they have
runoffs.
But wouldn't the runoffs also be rigged by
their own logic?
This all came to a glorious crescendo yesterday
on Fox and Friends when Lefler was interviewed
and she was asked, why wouldn't the January
runoff be just as rigged as the November election?
And she just she literally cannot explain
it.
Take a look at this.
We've heard from the president who said that
the election was stolen from him, that it
was rigged in November.
So for the people of Georgia who are thinking
about early voting, what can you say to them?
They've heard the election was rigged in November.
So why vote now?
Well, Steve, great question, because we've
built a robust organization to make sure that
every legal vote is counted and every illegal
vote is thrown out.
So what's different now than it was in November
where it's no longer rigged?
Yeah, so we're in the courts right now asking
for better signature verification processes,
a bipartisan verification to have consistent
verification county to county, as well as
the addition of four thousand poll watchers.
We also have a statewide organization getting
out the vote.
One thousand workers going across the state
backed by 40 thousand volunteers.
If we vote, we will win.
If we don't vote, we will lose the country.
We are the firewall to socialism.
And you saw in my debate last week, I'm running
against the most radically liberal candidate
that has ever run for the Senate.
He's someone that would defund the police.
He refused to renounce socialism.
We have to push back against this radical
agenda of the left and it's up to Georgia
voters to do that.
Great question, she says.
And and listen to her her explanations.
We now have an organization to count every
legal vote.
Well, right.
But that's that's.
Ah, you're doing that for November.
Well, how is that even relate to what has
changed in the system?
She says we're in the courts.
Well, but none of that's going anywhere.
And then she says we're really working hard
to get out the vote, get out.
The vote is campaigning.
It has nothing to do with rigging.
And then she just goes into socialism and
attacks her opponent, Raphael Warnock.
She can't answer the question, so she just
has her buzzwords from the debate.
But this was a totally different question.
If you believe it was rigged in November and
your vote wasn't counted accurately or at
all, why would you vote this time?
Because nothing has changed.
And it's a great question.
And she says, well, because my opponents are
radical.
OK, that's not really an answer.
And it's actually a disaster.
And really depressing that these races in
Georgia are even close, but they are close
in John OSV versus David Perdue.
The average of recent polling is USCIRF plus
one, which means it's tied could go either
way, which means you have to vote in Lefler
versus Warnock.
It's Warnock's plus one point six.
Again, whether you do or don't trust these
polls, you have to vote.
If we trust these polls, it's close and we
have to vote.
If we don't trust these polls, we don't know
how close it is.
So we have to vote either way.
We have to vote.
And it would be a major accomplishment.
Major accomplishment.
To be able to, after everything that's gone
down, take control of the Senate 50 50 with
Comilla as the deciding vote January 5th is
the day just a few weeks left and we will
know who is ultimately going
to control the Senate.